un giorno qualche mese fa ero nel mio
negozio di informatica ed entra una
famiglia che contro bambini e mi chiede
di vedere un tablet
io ne tirò fuori qualcuno faccio vedere
uno lo accendo il bambino subito inizia
a guardarlo a giocarci la mamma vede che
nella schermata principale è presente
l'icona di facebook mi diceva bene mi fa
piacere che ci sia già di corea di
facebook così può utilizzare facebook
però non voglio che che utilizzino la
rete i miei figli
io ho chiesto ma facebook comunque
funziona con la rete come mai non vuole
che sui figli utilizzino la rete perché
pericolose e facebook invece
completamente svincolato dalla rete
io quindi partendo da questo fatto la
riflessione mi sono detto ma come mai
non c'è questa consapevolezza negli
strumenti che usiamo tutti i giorni come
può essere un tablet un telefonino in
molte occasioni viene a mancare proprio
questa consapevolezza digitale nei più
piccoli e negli educatori genitori che
dovrebbero insegnare lo quindi questo mi
ha portato a incrementare maggiormente
le mie le mie risorse proprio sulla
sinergia tra educazione e consapevolezza
digitale io ho un'azienda che produce
una chiavetta con un sistema operativo
dedicato ai bambini dai 3 ai 10 anni e
sono qui per raccontarvi quella che era
la mia esperienza
quello che ho imparato in questi questi
anni che ho collaborato con con i
bambini
e voglio partire da questa frase di
sidney j harris
lo scopo dell'educazione è quella di
trasformare gli specchi in finestre
guardiamo ad esempio questo panorama
questo panorama possiamo scorgerlo
capirlo o di proprio perché abbiamo alla
base una cultura una formazione
un'istruzione che ci permette di
apprezzarlo appieno e sono necessari
sempre più strumenti nuovi innovativi
per poter capire il mondo che ci
circonda è assolutamente fondamentale
questa consapevolezza che utilizzare la
tecnologia per capire il mondo io gli
faccio un piccolo esempio molto banali o
26 anni sono solo giovani però quando
andavo alle scuole elementari e mi
davano come compito di fare una ricerca
io dovevo prendere andare in biblioteca
sfogliare i manuali e trovare i
contenuti che mi interessavano mentre
invece adesso un bambino può
semplicemente andare a ricercare i
contenuti che gli interessano
sulla rete trovare quello che gli serve
e portare a termine il compito quindi
non dobbiamo più chiederci se i bambi
far usare la tecnologia ai bambini o se
vietarla ai bambini ma dobbiamo
chiederci come far utilizzare questa
tecnologia ai bambini e sarà
assolutamente fondamentale capire come
incuriosirli come spingervi a informarsi
a utilizzare questi strumenti
tecnologici per alimentare la loro la
loro curiosità la rete sicuramente una
risposta a questa a questa esigenza non
è l'unica ma è una delle più importanti
guardiamo ad esempio questo tramonto
bellissimo vediamo una bambina seduta
sul suo zaino con uno smartphone in mano
ci chiediamo ma l'avrà visto questo
panorama che la circonda sì
probabilmente l'avrà visto prima di
utilizzare il telefono però forse ancora
più probabile che questa bambina l'abbia
visto l'abbia fotografato e lo stia
inviando a una
la sua amica e questa è la tecnologia
che circonda ormai tutti noi e tutti i
bambini lo sarà sempre di più presente
all'interno della della vita di tutti i
nostri nostri bambini
quindi dobbiamo chiederci come fare
avvicinare i bambini ei più piccoli al
web e al mondo digitale nel modo
migliore
innanzitutto dobbiamo fornirgli dei
supporti tecnologici adeguati
dobbiamo costruire in loro una
consapevolezza dargli un equilibrio e
questo lo possiamo fare solo attraverso
la guida da parte dei genitori degli
educatori degli insegnanti la
costruzione della consapevolezza passa
da partire dalle domande base sapere che
cos'è internet sapere che cos'è un
computer
cosa sono le applicazioni quali sono i
rischi e soprattutto sapere cosa fare se
incontrano un rischio la problematica
dobbiamo capire che se i bambini sono
consapevoli di quello che stanno
utilizzando riescono a sfruttare appieno
la rete tecnologie per ottenere
informazioni e di conseguenza formazione
cultura e stimolare in questo modo
ancora maggiormente la loro curiosità e
sfruttare tutte quelle che sono le
infinite possibilità che la rete offre
loro
questa è una ricerca della di ipsos per
save the children in cui viene detto che
i nativi digitali non sono per forza di
cose anche sapienti digitali o
consapevoli digitali per spesso non non
sanno non hanno un background il know
how che hanno quelli che vengono chiede
gli immigrati digitali che poi sono
quelli che hanno costruito costruito
quella rete e le tecnologie
quindi dobbiamo puntare molto sulla
costruzione della consapevolezza e su un
istruzione sulle tecnologie e sulla
sulla rete risulta molto importante
questo infatti io spesso quando nel mio
laboratorio
chiedo ai bambini ma cosa fai se
incontri un rischio se qualcuno
in molesta su facebook sulla rete e la
maggior parte non non mi sa rispondere
questo perché manca una consapevolezza
di fondo e poi ovviamente c'è bisogno di
un equilibrio quindi bisogna dedicare il
giusto tempo le tecnologie ma bisogna
anche poi uscire e a prendere altre cose
in altro in altro modo
quindi diciamo che essere digitalmente
consapevoli e assolutamente la chiave
per creare più importante vi porto vi
porto un esempio a proposito di
consapevolezza
quest'estate poco prima che finisse la
scuola era nel mio laboratorio stavamo
facendo un corso con dei bambini e io ho
chiesto così giusto per ma voi cosa
farete quest'estate quando inizia alle
vacanze una bambina mi ha risposto ma
guarda noi abbiamo studiato durante
l'anno chitarra e io volevo continuare a
studiare la durante l'estate per
approfondirla medio per imparare a
suonarla meglio e con i miei genitori
siamo andati su internet abbiamo abbiamo
cercato su youtube
abbiamo trovato dei video corsi che mi
permettono di imparare a suonare
chitarra stando a casa senza spendere
soldi e io sto consolidare quello che ho
appreso in classe quindi questo per dire
che la consapevolezza ci permette e
permettervi di utilizzare tutta la
tecnologia in modo efficace
quindi tecnologia e consapevolezza ed
educazione sono assolutamente
indissolubili tra loro e non bisogna
chiedere se far utilizzare la tecnologia
umile bambini ma bisogna soprattutto
chiedersi come rendere questa tecnologia
utile è utilizzabile da tutti grazie